the expanse is a sci-fi show based on a
series of books it's got drama politics
mysteries space battles space lasagna
and the later seasons get really wild
the expanse is set in a future where
humans have colonized the solar system
earth is the old superpower
overpopulated and in decline Mars is an
independent world with strong science
and military working to terraform Mars
to transform the Red Rock into a garden
the people of the asteroid belt are
called belters they live dangerous lives
on the frontiers of space and have their
own culture and language at the start of
the story scientists find a mysterious
alien virus called the proto molecule
Earth Mars and the belt get into
conflict trying to control it and in the
first three seasons the heroes of the
story managed to end this war but the
proto molecule grows into the ring a
kind of wormhole connecting to thousands
of new habitable worlds so who are the
main characters facing this new frontier
in season four Holden is a brave heroic
leader he was born on earth to a family
of eight parents five fathers and three
mothers who all contributed to Holden's
DNA they ran a farm in Montana and
raised Holden to stand up for truth and
justice he served in the earth space
Navy but quit when he was ordered to
fire on civilians so at the start of the
story
Holden's on a ship called the Canterbury
until it's suddenly destroyed as part of
a proto molecule conspiracy so Holden
steps up as a leader and fights to
protect his crew Alex amos and naomi the
dangers they face bring them together as
an unlikely family on a ship called the
Ross and ante Holden can be naive and
impulsive so Naomi challenges him to
make smarter decisions they start a
relationship bonding over their shared
determination to do what's right the
crew investigate the proto molecule and
Holden meets detective Miller Miller is
cynical and brutal which challenges
Holden's heroic ideals Miller shows that
to get [ __ ] done
sometimes you got to be morally flexible
so sometimes Holden does bad things for
the greater good even killing innocent
people to save others but Naomi reminds
Holden of his humanity and helps him to
stay grounded
Holden struggles with being a leader and
being a hero but when push comes to
shove he's always willing to risk his
life to save others in season 2 miller
dies crashing into venus with a moon
full of proto molecule but in season 3
Holden has visions of Miller the proto
molecule uses Miller's consciousness as
a tool to communicate with Holden the
alien intelligence behind the molecule
guide told him to open the ring gates
so now Holden and his crew face the
mystery and danger of alien worlds naomi
is a smart skilled engineer she is a
belter with a secret past
she was once involved with a radical
faction of the OPA a group fighting for
belter rights she had a son with an OPA
guy but the father took the baby away
from her and Naomi was on a mission
where innocent people died so Naomi is
haunted with trauma and guilt she found
support on the cat with Amos Amos is
strange
he's unemotional and violent but Naomi
helps Amos to make moral decisions and
Amos reassures Naomi that she's a good
person no matter what happened in her
past in the conflict over the proto
molecule it's the belters who suffer
most which reminds Naomi of her loyalty
to her people so against the wishes of
Holden and the crew Naomi gives a proto
molecule sample to the OPA and she
leaves the Rosi to join a belter ship
Holden and Amos feel betrayed but Naomi
believes in the belt and in their
mission to build an independent belter
nation naomi is close friends with OPA
leader drummer and helps her out in
season 3 but in the end Naomi returns to
the Rawson onte and to Holden Amos and
Alex because while the belters are her
people the Rosi crew are
family and her home Amos is a mechanic
born on earth he's tough blunt and
emotionally detached
he's secretive about his past but it's
implied that he was sexually exploited
as a child as part of organized crime in
Baltimore he learned to suppress all
emotion and do whatever's necessary to
survive he uses brutal violence with no
hesitation or remorse sometimes he gets
in fights with his friends like Alex he
knows he's not good at making the right
choices so that's why he's so reliant on
Naomi she's his guide star lighting the
way through the dark so when Naomi
leaves the Rosi Amos is forced to think
for himself some more he makes new
friendships with Anna and prax cos
despite all the darkness in Amos he's a
funny and lovable guy fans call him
murder snuggles cuz he's affectionate
and honest and loyal and vulnerable and
he's trying so hard to be a better man
alex is a cheerful Martian pilot with a
Texan accent and a fondness for country
music he flew with a Martian Navy and
discovered his passion for spaceflight
he has a wife and child on Mars but he's
left them behind because he believes his
true purpose is to fly with the rawson
Dante doing good and saving lives
Holden Naomi and Amos are Alex's family
now but there is a sadness to Alex that
he's estranged from his wife and child
he finds comfort in a friendship with
Bobby Martian Marine Alex's expertise as
a pilot saves the Rocinante countless
times so the main heroes of the story of
the Rosi crew Holden Naomi Amos and Alex
on earth there's other Sarala a powerful
politician in the United Nations which
controls earth of a Sarala is charming
and scheming and sassy as all [ __ ] in
season one she's ruthless in defending
Earth's power she tortures and
blackmails and betrays a friend because
years ago Avasarala son was killed by
the OPA and she's determined to protect
her
remaining family she believes earth
comes first and she'll do anything to
defend her home but other Sarala
uncovers corruption within her own
government her colleague Aaron Wright
conspires to weaponize the proto
molecule so other Sarala works with the
Rosi crew and with belters and martians
and risks her own life to stop Aaron
right and prevent war Avasarala learns
to see the humanity in all people in
belters and Martians as well as earthers
in season 3 she becomes
secretary-general the most powerful
person on earth and she urges peace and
unity as humanity faces new worlds
beyond the ring Bobby is a Martian
Marine a tough and confident warrior she
comes from a military family and was
fiercely loyal to Mars at the start of
season 2 she couldn't wait for a war to
wipe out earth but on Ganymede her squad
is killed by a proto molecule creature
and Bobby discovers that her own Martian
government unleashed this monster to
test it as a weapon
so Bobby rebels against Mars and brings
the truth to other Sarala
Bobby helps the earth government that
she had once hoped to destroy and fights
for the greater good in season three she
rejoins the Martians but then she turns
against them to help hold him Bobby is a
Martian and a soldier and she wants to
fight for good but she says the hardest
part of this game is figuring out who
the enemy really is drama is a leader of
the OPA fighting for a future for
belters she is proud uncompromising
fiercely loyal to the belt and also
pretty good at space handball in season
three she becomes the captain of the
behemoth the massive OPA ship drummers
legs are crushed in an accident so Naomi
sets up a mech so that she can walk
drummer and Naomi's friendship runs deep
and it's tied to their identities as
belters so by the end of season 3 Earth
Mars and the belt are at a delicate pace
but the new worlds beyond the ring gate
promise more conflict and more mystery
what alien race made the gates and what
happened to them what new dangers will
Naomi Alex and Amos face how will the
ring effect of a Cyril on earth Bobby on
Mars and drummer in the OPA is peace and
humanity possible in the cold vast
expanse season four streams on Amazon
Prime video on December 13th for more
alt shift X videos please like subscribe
and comment thanks to Amazon for
sponsoring this video and thanks to the
patrons including a mobile car corral
car Acedo : Canon Jerome Froelich Jura
Val Catalan Manu Gupta and grimace
Cheers
you